pop
[Musique]
l'implant les vieux et sommiers
et la bouche
et divine août par exemple monsieur
petit monsieur side
je vous présente qui dit mieux
bien sûr dit curieux comme tu lèves tu
veux savoir qui est si et bam si c'est
nous c'est le capot pour papa pour la
fête des pères
et voilà c'est pourquoi pas mais fait
pipe
vous autres crocodiles bouche mais pas
la pipe
l'échographie talibans dim
j'ai marqué des paniers j'ai pas fait
tout un art on ira en finale contre
l'envolée bas j'y suis allé la veille
c'est toi fais tout ce boucan
je crois que tout a fait daccord bonnes
mains c'est pas le moral qui déchoit
basket comme moi pour ressembler dans le
train et par un sac de pommes de terre
merci aux élus dont basket et marco
dormino c'est plus cher que tu es gay
juillet
pourquoi patinoire aussi savoir c'est
les beatles alors magro me fais tuer m x
ne marche plus forcément à rejeter les
ressorts de la bouche quoi j'en avais
besoin pour mon invention qui tacle en
valeur soit ramenée à 12 cm je ne ris
pas tu rigoles ou quoi aux gens notre
bazar aujourd'hui c'est pas le changer
le match ouest et puis dimanche alors
voilà vidic tabac le fait la vie cette
réponse a les oreilles au cinéma vidéo
commentée numéro des têtes l'europe le
saule pleureur te dit est dit que tu dis
rien du tout tu paies un coup moi
simplement fait son rêve c'est de la
dignité et j'aime pas qu'on pique mes
pots de crème revitalisante aurait dû
dont nous allons faire de bons en
première partie le paquet pour
poursuivre des gnons qui m'agace
en fait je veux mon salon
oui mais très peu de 49 ans donc c'est
ma part je vois tant les mots bleus
bon et bien on reçu un autre tu ne t'en
fais pas seul non parce que tous ont
essayé de porter un bidule machin
chouette de saint cloud j'aime pas de
s'arranger côté c'est moi je n'en ratez
pas eh bien je ne comprends pas après
tout
et oui la farine délais
bien il y aura un look et sita baja
morts
[Musique]
une marche aux marais c'est pour toi
duffy car tu veux encore looké comme
d'autres jouent elles seront obligées de
te mettre du mercurochrome
tout ce que j'ai fait pour la fête des
papas demain montre moi ça me tue c'est
que ce formidable c'est merveilleux
c'est un bloc celui qui tombe
m'apercevrai tout de suite voir est ce
que tu sais pourquoi s'y faire à la main
avec un glaucome ce que jamais très bien
moyon réfléchissons un peu
elle doit une réponse aux poussettes qui
domina donc oui eh ben tu vois je crois
que j'ai trouvé mois les cooking
c'est pour mettre des boutons de
manchette pas mal bonne idée qu'est ce
que ces moutons moche est au bout tu
sais bien voyons c'est pour attacher les
éléments du cht is alors que perthus et
pourquoi pas mettre ses piques aux beaux
jours et dont il pense en fait tu sais
que ces traits faciaux nabeul comme
disent les anglais j'ai fait ses frais
et toi qu'est ce que tu as fait a battu
vois je fais comme toi je suis en train
de préparer mon cadeau pour ja demain
ils vont nous ne sommes pas assis toi tu
vas voir
alors histoire mon métier d'institutrice
qui va défendre moi à moins de quarante
enfants des favoris les blesse quand
même qui en avait pas mais lorsqu'il
pose et de la houle était repassé en or
ici votre mari était veuf a pour part de
roue puisque on arriverait nombre
ça fait plus confiance il n'a pas
attendu d'être parce que je voulais dire
je suis trop dans cette maison aunac
mais qu'est ce que ça fait là ça
enfin robin on voit quoi c'est pas
normal quoi si ne n'est pas là pour être
consciente et de paix les tiger est fait
pour être belle
autour du salon des enfants a besoin de
vous conseiller
mais un jour je mettrai jamais venu dans
la peur toute la famille se pose tout
est prêt lawrence avenue des pins gris
va vite et je partirai tient aujourd'hui
peut-être et bamako
qu'est ce que vous faites les blues pop
art a écrit j'ai déjà demandé novembre
les mollahs mais d'abord qu'est ce que
c'est la glauque comprends je sais
pourquoi tu disparais sharad hett trouve
ça normal
on veut c'est de sa génération soit son
âge tu disait malade pourquoi nahd est
bien bien pour manger que t'as pas
empêché d'enseigner le français au jeu
mais naturellement si tu donnes que je
raison est résistant de papa viens de
voir ça sert j'ai besoin de musique
justement
mais alors discuter mais pourquoi le
plus comité le quitter car deux tâches
au dessus de celle de la chaîne nhk
écoute moi pour le poteau jat1 on le
ramène
et après je te dirais le troisième
chapitre du roman policier je suis en
train d'écrire
que doit-on affiche sa volonté divine et
je me demandais ce que c'était pardon
des dix pardon tu mènes
[Musique]
oh ya personne
parfois je viens
qu'est ce que la caisse qu'elle avait
vendu voilà voilà que le drame couve
dans sa famille explique toi mais tu
sais très bien est ce que tu veux dire
le chien peut on en reparlera
papili pas du reste la table regarde pas
patrice moi je ne joue pas au welsh peut
plus tricher n'a pas produit avant qu'il
quitte à manquer en pas douter ce soir
lors de la visite mais tu vois tu me le
dis à noter chez le coiffeur
c'est la boutique à tous les mardis soir
exactement quel âge à la kate est déjà
père curieux on a des regrets car après
tout venant mercredi un peu de respect
pour votre père de mérite et non vous
allez droit savoir elle s'appelle
clotilde mais tout le monde l'appelle et
chloé la 34 ans elle est célibataire
paul houde défi j'ai peut-être la
rendait donc l'eau des régimes de
retraite en piqué ma mort non je ne suis
pas marrant et que fait-elle cette
demoiselle clotilde si tu veux déjà
plaisir à bella clos est bien vrai que
sa priorité au monsieur charmant sourire
frivolité mon titre écrite et rivalités
oui oui oui
elles vont des groupes pas drôle elle
vous aurez envie de vous connaître c'est
pour ça que j'ai invité à prendre un
verre j'espère que vous avez dû faire
bonne impression
[Musique]
marleix
tout est toujours à retard dû aux
français ce n'est pas grave enfin de son
portable devient champion encore une
partie qu'ils ont battus pas gagné je le
sens oui j'écoute ainsi bah ouais je
vous comprends bien je vais chercher mes
pilules papy ch
il faut que tu m'aides toi tu as fait
une bête et popi non non si éviter pour
la première fois une surboum sur sa
vitalité boys band ten oui j'ai jamais
entendu parler de celui là c'est un type
sympa dès que je l'aï vu et il m'a trop
s'y fier t'as quoi atrassi fier ça veut
dire qu il te fait une impression du
tonnerre tu le regardes et tu restes à
sifié ya pas de tout repos pour désigner
ça c'est à dire que le montant visé
machar mais il a ses limites enfin je
présume que ça veut dire la même chose
avis aux candidats et où là tu connu ce
bob et en seconde on bâille feu plus
jeune vous pouviez doivent voir que ces
parfums la seconde il va être très jeune
pour même il fit qui ne vont pas sur
boom
c'est ce qui leur arrive pas on les
regrette
tu parles pour les bonnes cotes
personnel rien dit waouh
photo jack guez et ben d'ivoire au fait
qu'est ce que je viens faire là dedans
tout ça moi voilà j'ai pensé que tu
pourras peut-être demander la permission
pour toi ou là
ce polo tu as vingt minutes ici son
copain de bob tu seras les convaincre
alors ma fille je ne peux pas prendre
une telle responsabilité
à moins que j'ai peut-être une idée
oui mais que j'aille avec toi ya des
jeunes est alors le plus jeune 17 ans
mais j'adore la jeunesse moi qui suis
sûr que le règlement actuel ne furent
pas pisser contre c'est délicat
on est son grand père à une sur la
demande
lambert belge en tort mais aucune
qualité à une sur banshee dans le
mélange plus proche
la pop pour ensuite enfin tu peur non
plus dans la région c'est son large avec
un garçon comme qu'un effort il aurait
fallu que nous présente n'importe
comment ce soir c'est impossible donc
tout le monde soit là pour accueillir
les invités pour repère pour une bonne
femme moi toute ma vie serait une
victime
mon dieu faites que ça marche au n'a pas
entendu à l'eau est ce que je pourrais
pas là bob s'il vous plaît de la part de
vérone l'instant je t'aime pardon
j'avais pas reconnu ta voix didon vieux
tu ne m'en voudra pas mais je peux pas
sûr que ce soit avec toi
[Applaudissements]
j'y vais
monsieur vincent rugby même pas de vent
d'automne je suis le fils d'edgar en
automne et un ami de vos cris véronique
justement elle m'avait prêté des livres
de classe je passais par là je me suis
dit que je vais m'arrêter on ne sait
jamais mais rentrez chez vous un prix
salue quand il va le rester on perd
cricri benoish que quelques instants un
nom chez vous un peu petit poucet pas
mal de bons vacances via l'équipe
connaisse comment tu le trouves les
soignants non quand elle parle de moi
véro exagère toujours tout cas je fais
confiance à son jugement seront là bien
vers la tendance à moi aussi tient à
luiz qui tombe mal pour le foie moi je
préfère un jus de pomme si ça vous
dérange pas et si vous avez tous deux
vont se chercher
ça fait au moins deux mois
on lui reproche parfois son caractère
c'est une gosse voyons celui passera
d'ailleurs sainement vous imaginez pas
comme ça au nom si vous entendiez verrou
parlez vous on s'attend à rencontrer
paul newman ou marlon brando tombeur
quoi ah oui vous me trouvez disant un
peu bourgeois ce sera non pour un père
vous êtes plutôt bien si vous voyez bien
à côté avec sa tête de coffre-fort
forcément il est banquier avec moi faut
s'habituer je dis n'importe quoi je
parle et les gens font de tri avec les
filles cette méthode là je vous la
recommande ça marche du tonnerre et dont
les séries
j'ajoute en prix
qu'est ce que tu fabriques dans cette
bio à 12h06 toutes les masses à ta soeur
ça marche avait pas de vérité ta soeur
quand on se voit on n'a jamais autant
parlé on s'est connus au skating saleix
d'un copain était légèrement en panne et
à nous deux on la répare et papa de
m'excuser j'ai besoin que bon me donne
un coup de main alors revenons ici je
pensais pas que j'allais passer une si
bonne soit parce qu'elle fait que la
team mais en tout cas moi je perds mon
temps
le tabac moi je savais que pape a salué
sa marge limite on met notre vie
nouvelle et très belle invention
oui mais cette petite chienne son bambin
fait ce qu'elle veut or tu vois tu
appuies sur pluton tu poses jusqu'à
ceque qu'on allait voir
je viens je ne fais plus haut mais je
vous en prie merci ça chauffe
elle a quitté son bureau est comme ça
que tous attendent oui mais alors si que
l'ubs et oublie de le retirer alors j'ai
pensé aussi en tous cas c'est oui mais
c'était tout seul 2 3 4
si c'est oui
mac os mais aussi pourquoi y avait
demandé 5 gt pour moi c'est la
résistance que grille et je suis
maintenant puisqu'on y rouler au pas ton
père un allume cigare enfin lui de
belles boîtes d'allumettes non c'est pas
vrai c'est important la même chose ça
qu'à écrire un poème qui me colle qu'est
ce qu'un blu convaincant ça t'es gentil
mais ton cadeau c'est un gâteau qu'est
ce qu'on peut bien en faire un art à moi
pour ma
mais ta grand mère ma vraie toujours un
gros gâteau tu crois qu'elle viendra
clotilde
jdo
alors ces critiques oui non rouge à la
base de trucs et une panne de voiture
je ne passe pas par la clau qu'est ce
qui t'arrive tu vas le chercher
enfin tant pis on se rappelle demain
soir c'est aux abris
[Musique]
bon pour ce soir dont je vais forage et
de mandoline
[Applaudissements]
il s'agissait d'un ouvrage de surfing
structure de l'atome et ligne spectrale
et donc qu'est ce que ça veut dire
l'hymne spectrale
comment veux tu que je sache mais la
seconde pourrait savoir marc labarbe tu
crois pas que d'autres problèmes de la
faute de platine j'ai même pas été à la
surboum turin doutre sûr quand il était
venu c'est pour sa patte à une fille
drôle de tête
je le comprends quand on attend une
femme et tout ça pour une bonne part
venue trop jeunes évidemment tu peux pas
comprendre mais pour un homme une femme
c'est l'essentiel
c'est tout tu crois puisque je te le dis
d'ici qu'est ce que je vais offrir un
papa pour la fête des pères
n'importe quoi ça lui fera toujours
plaisir fait bien des sa petite bête tu
comprends rien je vais offrir à papa
pour la fête des pères
une femme
[Musique]
oh
non non non mais j'en passe vous n'êtes
pas et puis on se fait mark et moi je
trouve cette idée charmant papa pour
faire aujourd'hui c'est la fête des
pères je suis sûr que dans toute la
france une seule jeune fille aurait eu
l'idée saugrenue ayant peut-être pas
pensé
en fait il pas du tout c'est un beau
cadeau pour rien je ne dis pas le
contraire
mon grand malheur on disait souvent
c'est le plus beau cadeau tu vois si
luke mcalister prévu claudie pour une
progresse donc je ne dis pas non pas
c'est délicat mais transformés en postes
à vous énerver pas toutes les deux comme
ça si ce n'est que pour le café
voulez-vous que j'habite faisait le
point nous sommes de parker elles
viennent le violet représente plus que
moi olimpa oui alors il est toujours
très nerveuse et je refais est un peu
confus je suis assez de l'ami de claudie
et aussi de ce monsieur là bon de
trouver mieux que vous êtes foyers
contre pas de charme en faisait partie
il était comme il faut mais pas coulés
par soi même
saleh j'ai trouvé mes docteurs perché à
2 oui on le provoque les plus je vais
chercher pas qu'au garage où il était
pas encore arrivé
alors le docteur m'a demandé si je
voulais dire automative débit sans joie
des parents car voiture avec un ordre
d'une connexion laissait pas assez
difficile une doctoresse site et mieux
car c'est la blonde qui ressemble
vachement à françoise hardy ligne de
champion du monde est dedans oui
oreilles social ya de ça deux chevaux
pour faire ces visites
mais il semble avoir rencontré cette
jeune personne allait très bien elle a
souvent un rail en belgique
oui ben parfaite elle a du chien oui
enfin du chiffre de l'élégance si tu
préfères on évite personne ne la connaît
japonais elle m'a même donné son numéro
téléphone allait bien mais sa main
[Musique]
sebbar et prenons chic
ouais à nous de les héberger
c'est claudie l'appareil conseil des
ministres non je voudrais bien mais
c'est pas pour ça que je vous appelle
tous librement des gens enfin si vous
voulez de casser tout parlementaire
[Applaudissements]
alors bonjour la moselle
excusez-moi de vous importuner mais ma
petite fille claudine vous la connaissez
oui à d'espiet que voilà et ben je vais
droit trop vous de vous le feriez le
plus grand plaisir
au moment de voir au val d'oise elle
vous avez une voix si charmante non vous
n'allez pas refuser ce grand plaisir à
ma petite fille très aimable merci
beaucoup à faire
vers 2h savait où c'est à la grande
maison au fond du jardin
n'hésitez pas à me poser mon petit-fils
vais vous dire un mot madame biblique
est malade qui fait des transferts mardi
10 au crocodile
à côté il est gentil il ne fait jamais
de mal à personne tu prends un choix ni
la nano ventre promesses et de même la
dette rouge noir est toujours cote aa
promis à mon arrivée
[Applaudissements]
j'aurais l'air pour une fois je reprends
de 17 ans gars
[Musique]
tu es une amie de cody je crois qu'elle
l'a invité à prendre le café
maintenant hébergés pas par mon père et
moi je suis très heureux de vous
connaître
ça nous a beaucoup parlé olemps vous
fait peur c'est un très bon supporter lé
docteur au docteur qui donne envie
d'être malade ses rangs mon grand-père
savez je ne m'occupe que des enfants des
jambes et vous savez je le sens
terriblement jeunes oh là là très très
gamin presque un enfant
enfin que vous pensez vanoise lb et
c'est mon père parfois j'ai l'impression
d'avoir un fils de plus et à trotter
ambulants j'espère s'ils souffrent aussi
chaud toi qui as crocodile malades
il s'appelle débit les ramasseurs
suppose que c'est véronique c'est mon
second prénom tout le monde m'appelle 0
quand j'avais ton âge on va appeler riri
pour marie tu vois que tu as de la
chance inattendue ce père ça y est la
bienvenue dans le premier au bout d'un
parcours mais essayez vous je vous en
prie cette maison de ravissants et oui
nous l'avons achetée avec ma femme en
on suppute un trou de campagne ici à ce
moment là il y avait une ferme juste à
côté est pris notamment d'ailleurs fait
une excellente affaire
à voir sa excellente affaire en
réparation ne coûte un peu moins cher
qu'un château de versailles printemps
sur la scène raconte il faut toujours
schéma tactique devront aller chercher
le champagne dans la cuisine
excusez moi
oui donc - une petite place foch et rue
du genre mignonne merci savez vous que
j'ai eue pour marraine une des premières
femmes docteur de france au futur un
personnage étonnant elle passait son
temps à manger des truffes et un jour
dans un grand restaurant
et d'après une cigarette et elle a fumé
ce scandale
les gens montés sur lui chaises pour
l'avoir à la musique à l'époque les
femmes ne fait mais pas en public
qu'est ce ça ne vous empêche pas d'en
prendre une
pas toujours des enfants délinquants les
parents c'est pillent
ça mérite le ballon mais qu'est ce qui
vous arrive et l'aurait fait divers un
joli faits divers et qui se passe dans
une maison de fous donc je suis de votre
avis rien de plus effrayant café avec sa
voix et vous je vous dis monsieur
jacques gillot honte pour vous bien sûr
je vous saviez pas vous avez fait il ça
joue l'innocent
si le malheur fond sur cette famille
vous dirai pas que je dis pas prévenu
dès lors il ya dix ans vous êtes dans
cette famille je commence à être habitué
a voulu by sleep
mais jamais jamais il lui dit que
j'allais voir que bientôt c'est vrai que
je parte ordre on voit la poutre dans
l'oeil de son voisin et pas la part
d'anciens plus facile de détourner la
conversation honorine à des lubies
honorine si ces projets de travers en
attendant aux laurines pendant ce
qu'elle pense
et qu'est ce qu'elle pense honorine
honorine le sait bien allez je veux
démarrer
je suis qu'un jeu
je suis d'un tempérament posée mais
allez vous me dire ce que pensent
honorine satie le complètement faux
quand je vous disais c'est moi qui la
partagent maintenant c'est un match
chris paul comment la pluie bonhomme qui
se souvient de sa fille de 12 ans pour
attirer des femmes si l'uci pour l'album
de berger savez bien vous seriez obligé
la truie une aventure jan berger les
bonaventure hier un docteur et à tous
ces sondages dont vous donnez aux tuyaux
pour ridiculiser le berger et docteurs
et je n'ai jamais demandé à claude y
donne des sujets bien j'ai deux
complices tpiy c'est facile je me la
committee heureusement honorine va clair
claudine votre fille votre propre finit
à 12 ans ont frappé une femme comme
cadeau pour la fête des pères
il me trouvais ça marrant si le mâle
alpha sur cette raison je sais il a fait
ça il faut ça qui fait charmant
effectuée jeudi à gaza les besoins d'une
mère il faut que je me marie on dit ça
enfin tu me voyais je dirais plus leur
hymne
claudine très bon goût cette manne aux
jeunes bergers je la trouve charmant
si le vit mal cette maison
ra plus grave que ces jolies que c'est
joli
merci que l'écrit à ça je devine de qui
s'est accéléré
merci claudie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]